[Music]
on bangladesh's south coast
homes don't just flood they disappear
we're heading to a village called
calabogie
surrounded by a rising river battered by
cyclones this land of mud and sediment
is being washed away taking homes
and hope along with it
rising sea levels in the bay of bengal
downstream
mean river tides here are getting higher
storm surges are more intense and
dangerous
than
people here are getting desperate there
is no land left for farming
fishing is all they've got and to try
and escape
poverty and debt they are prepared to
break the law
this village is on the edge of the
protected sunderbans forest
it's a unesco world heritage site and
it's illegal to fish here
but it's a rich habitat for wildlife
[Applause]
and at night next to the forest edge we
see flashlights on the water
there are dozens of fishermen here
when we get to nazarel's shake he thinks
we're the coast guard coming to chase
him away
these fine mesh nets are illegal too
but they catch more what he's doing now
is he's drawn the nets in and he
is sorting what has come up
and what he's looking for are these tiny
shrimp fries
like shrimp larvae and they look like
very very fine hairs and he's been out
here about
six hours and he's told us he's probably
caught enough to make about
13 dollars
tonight he says the catch is good it's a
brief reprieve
[Applause]
because although no one wants to leave
here in reality
they're running out of places to go
over there about 500 meters away is a
small island with homes on it until
about a year ago
that was connected to this bit of land
and it wasn't just
a road to walk on it was a stretch of
land that had homes on it where people
lived and when you see this and you
think about climate change goals and
climate change targets you like to think
that
action can make a difference but really
for people living here it's already too
late
this is why bangladesh says the world
must act
with this year's climate conference
needed not to talk about what will
happen
but about what's happening right here
right now
catherine of autopsy sky news in
kalibogi bangladesh